in ancient greece the changing seasons
depended on a magnificent mother and
daughter duo named demeter and
persephone the bringers of food and fair
weather these golden goddesses were
worshiped in lush harvest celebrations
but their story has a darker side one
involving violence tragic compromise and
a bittersweet resurrection revealing the
true depths of a mother-daughter bond
and important information about the
environment gender and the cycle of life
and death in ancient greece
as the goddess of agriculture demeter
spent her time not on mount olympus but
wandering farms and fields she had one
child with zeus a wheaton-haired goddess
known as corey or the girl who would
later become persephone while zeus
played the part of absent father classic
corey was always by her mother's side
but as she grew into a kind and lively
young woman she was being watched from
afar one day corey was picking
wildflowers with the water nymph cyan
when the ground began to shake beneath
their feet a jagged crack tore through
the earth belching noxious smoke and
enveloping the women as the smoke
cleared they saw the ghastly figure of
hades god of the dead and the underworld
of the same name in his ebony chariot
before cyan could react hades grabbed
corey and descended back down into the
underworld countless tellings of this
abduction exist
most of the older versions portray
cory's kidnapping as a moment of sexual
violence and hades who is also
persephone's uncle as a predator
later versions revise this dynamic some
emit references to abuse and translation
while others portray hades as a lonely
god whom corey eventually comes to love
what's clear is that corey was taken to
the underworld without her consent
resulting in chaos for both gods and
mortals at the scene of the crime cyan
wept her tears falling so fast that she
became one with the river by the time
demeter realized her daughter was
missing corey and cyan were nowhere to
be found
distraught demeter sought help on mount
olympus many gods had witnessed the
abduction but zeus himself had set it in
motion
without corey's consent or demeter's
knowledge he had granted hades his
daughter's hand in marriage he had even
instructed gaia the earth goddess to
make particularly stunning flowers grow
that day in order to lure corey to the
spot cowed by zeus's authority the other
gods stayed silent and so demeter lit
her torches from the volcanic fires of
mount etna saddled twin dragons to her
chariot and searched alone
day and night she looked for corey
crossing land and sea without stopping
for rest in her absence the crops grew
fallow plants withered and died color
seeped from the flowers and mortals
began to go hungry
ever imperius zeus ordered demeter to
return to her duties unsurprisingly she
refused
eventually demeter came to the site of
persephone's abduction
reduced to a pool of water cyan had lost
the ability to speak but she had
retained a key piece of evidence for the
goddess demeter spotted cory's hair
ribbon floating in the water clutching
the ribbon she sensed violence and
struggle but did not yet know where her
daughter was trapped meanwhile deep
under the earth across the river styx
and through the gloomy realms of hell
cory was fighting her own battle hades
expected her to serve as his wife but
she rejected his propositions and
refused all food and drink she knew that
one bite of the food of the dead was
enough to bind her to hades forever as
she slowly began to starve she prayed
that her mother would find her soon
finally demeter found the information
she needed in some reports it was the
all-seeing sun god helios who revealed
corey's whereabouts in others the nymph
arituza or the goddess of magic hecate
sounded the alarm armed with this
knowledge demeter headed straight to
zeus and demanded the return of their
daughter however it was too late zeus
informed demeter that corey had eaten
pomegranate seeds down in the underworld
again accounts vary about how corey came
to eat the seeds some say that hades
forced her to eat the food of the
underworld others claim she willingly
ate the fruit after haiti's seduction
and there are accounts where cory just
finally gave into her hunger and snuck a
few seeds either way this threatened to
ensnare her forever of course demeter
was not prepared to accept this she told
zeus that she would abandon her duties
forever letting the earth grow barren
and mortals go hungry zeus balked at
this prospect but at the same time the
laws of hades couldn't be broken
entirely with the help of the fates
shout out to our first episode they
reached an uneasy compromise corey would
reside in hades for several months one
for each seed for the remaining months
she would be permitted to rise to the
earth this compromise provided the
ancient greeks with a frame for
understanding season change when corey
was in hades the land grew barren and
cold as demeter retreated in her grief
but when she ascended to the earth their
joyful reunion caused the world to burst
into bloom while cory's ascent was
associated with rebirth her descent to
hades and the coming of the winter
months were inevitable for this reason
in her adult role corey was commonly
known as persephone or the bringer of
destruction
persephone stands for the bittersweet
cycle of life in which regeneration and
decay are twin forces the myth also has
a dual message when it comes to gender
roles on the one hand demeter and
persephone epitomize the power of divine
femininity but this power varies
depending on the source in the homeric
hymn to demeter the goddess is lauded
for her steely determination but hades
also has significant sway at times
everyone appears to be at the mercy of
him and zeus this is also the version
that helios another male god informs
demeter about persephone's fate of its
metamorphosis give women a different
role nymphs generally move the plot
forward from cyan offering the hair
ribbon to artusa sounding the alarm
across different versions of the myth
there's a power struggle at play between
the men who appear to make the decisions
and the women who subvert them
it may seem like the subversion only
works to a point demeter does not manage
to negotiate permanent freedom for her
daughter and persephone is forced to
marry a man she did not choose this
reflects real social conditions in
ancient greece
women had little control over their
affairs with their fathers brothers or
husbands presiding over their education
economic and marital lives teenage girls
could be married to much older men
including their uncles and that's not
the only parallel between persephone and
ancient greek brides
some greek wedding vases depict a
married couple riding in a chariot or
the groom leading the bride away while
her mother carries a torch
these have been interpreted as echoes of
persephone's abduction the separation of
mother and daughter and demeter's
torchlit quest
in another parallel women who died
before marriage were termed brides of
hades in these examples the myth of
hades and persephone looms over rites of
passage for young brides and the broader
power imbalances therein of course as
goddesses demeter and persephone can
overturn these imbalances demeter's
forbiddable power over life on earth
allows her to threaten and ultimately
cut a deal with zeus while persephone's
resurrection is a triumphant moment for
both mother and daughter while in hades
persephone ruled over the dead as her
husband's equal classical texts refer to
her as dreaded persephone depicting some
mortals as too afraid to utter her name
she can also set the furies on mortals
that displeased her or resurrect heroes
from the dead
on earth she marked the turning of the
seasons and the cycle of life and was
often celebrated in lavish ceremonies
her ascent to earth was at the center of
the illusion mysteries one of the oldest
and most secretive rituals in ancient
greece celebrated at harvest time these
rituals occurred at ellusis near athens
a place demeter was believed to have
stopped for rest during her search
subsequent interpretations of the myth
have explored its gendered power
dynamics in new context artisan writers
have used persephone to explore the
experience of women under patriarchy
throughout time as well as the power of
the mother-daughter bond in her poem the
pomegranate yvonne boland imagines her
younger self as persephone wandering
through unknown worlds before she
becomes demeter watching her own
daughter grow up there's also a flurry
of texts that imagine persephone's story
as both a coming-of-age tale and a
romance from tv specials to fiction and
graphic novels some of these rework the
source material like the episode of 90s
drama hercules where persephone
gradually falls in love with her captor
others paint a more complex picture set
in our modern day the webcomic lore
olympus imagines mount olympus as a
patriarchal kingdom rife with abuse but
at the heart of the story is a slow
burning love between persephone and
hades whether her story is presented as
violent abduction environmental parable
coming of age tale or forbidden love
story persephone is rarely disempowered
far from being a naive figure who either
becomes enamored with hades or functions
as his victim she is a formidable
goddess in her own right as the goddess
of rebirth and a terrifying bringer of
destruction persephone holds unique
power over both the living and the dead
as greek mythology's most important
liminal figure persephone retains the
precious balance between creation and
destruction abundance and deprivation
year after year she resurrects herself
and single-handedly sets the cycle of
life and death in motion
before you go big news for history buffs
like me pbs digital studios has a new
history theme channel called pbs origins
and we think you're gonna love it the
channel will be home to multiple shows
including a new series called historians
take the show explores history through
the lens of pop culture examining what
that culture can tell us about its time
period and what it means to our future
pbs origins will have even more new
stuff on the way so hit the link in the
description and subscribe to the channel
so you don't miss anything tell them dr
z sent you
you